[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes le 2 mai nouvelle
édition du 78 lactu le journal de la
rédaction nous allons faire le point sur
l'actualité du jour mais bien évidemment
comme chaque vendredi nous allons aussi
revenir sur les principaux sujets de
cette semaine on débute forcément par un
sujet de circonstances 1er mai jour du
muguet c'était hier et malgré une
cuillette qui s'est terminé bien en
avance en raison des températures plutôt
douces de ces dernières semaines la
demande a été visiblement satisfaite
l'enjeu est important 32 millions
d'euros c'est le montant estimé des
recettes à travers la France l'an passé
les images à 50 ans en Yveline de
Patrick Jacques de
dixmud c'est un incontournable pas de
1ier mai sans muguet marchand d'un jour
ou fleuriste tous étaient une fois de
plus prêt à répondre à la demande plus
de 30 millions d'euros seraient dépensés
en moyenne chaque année ce qui explique
la multiplication des points de vente
l'important pour capter le client est
alors de trouver un endroit stratégique
où installer son stand devant les
boulangeries dans les endroits où on
peut se garer facilement et dans les
petits centres là qui sont encore
ouverts il faut éviter les banques
évidemment parce que c'est fermé
évidemment mais bon dans les endroits en
règle générale là où il y a du passage
tout
simplement comment vous avez fait votre
choix il y a tris stand ici comment
pourquoi vous êtes allé chez Madame
parce que c'était le premier en sortant
de du magasin d'accord voilà que la dame
avait une tête
sympathique et une fois l'emplacement
trouvé le sourire affiché encore faut-il
pour le vendeur proposer un muguet de
bonne qualité cette année avec les
températures douces des dernières
semaines la floraison a été précoce il
est un peu ouvert parce qu'il est plus
précoce que les autres années mais
globalement ça reste correct parce que
l'an dernier il y en avait pratiquement
pas du fait qu'il avait fait très froid
donc cette année il est un petit peu
ouvert un petit peu plus que les autres
habitudes les autres années mais bon
globalement c'est c'est correct il y a
la quantité et puis par rapport au prix
d'achat l'an dernier c'est moins 20 %
environ et cela fait plus de 5 siècle
que cela dure symbole de chance et de
bonheur le muguet s'offrait déjà à la
cour de Charles ce n'est qu'au début du
20e siècle que le rapprochement avec la
fête du travail s'est effectué lorsque
des ouvriers l'ont arboré lors de
manifestation côté transport la SNCF
vient de dévoiler son plan de
modernisation du réseau et de la prise
en charge des voyageurs de la ligne C du
RER une ligne qui connaît de nombreuses
difficultés ces derniers mois Olivier
Manis calco David
charpentier réaliser 28 % d'usagers
insatisfait au 1er janvier 2014 c'est
deux points de plus qu'en 2013 la ligne
C du RER qui relie notamment 550 an en
Yveline cristallise pas mal de
mécontentement problème de ponctualité
de régularité en cause pour la SNCF un
matériel vieillissant et une
augmentation de 3 % de la fréquentation
depuis 10 ans une nouvelle phase de
travaux est lancée pour 6 ans sur notre
secteur la gare de versaill chantier va
être totalement revue mieux traiter
l'information voyageur mieux traiter les
flux et donc avoir des des espaces mieux
dimensionnés rénover la gare et puis
l'intermodalité également avec les les
autres modes de transport donc c'est
vraiment c'est pas juste la gare c'est
ce qu'on appelle le pôle d'échange
multimodale de versaill chantier qui va
être complètement rénové ce ne sera pas
sans conséquence pour les voyageur
puisque jusqu'au mois de novembre 32
weekends de fermeture sont programmés et
à chaque fois qu'on est qu'on a des
travaux sur versaill et qui ont des
conséquences voyageurs on met en place
un plan de de substitution ou de
redéploiement vers vers d'autres lignes
parce qu'il y a certains moments où la
ligne N elleelle peut circuler ça dépend
ça dépend des des conséquences travaux
il y en a pas y a pas une seule
conséquence il a plusieurs types de
conséquences travaux ou alors on met des
bus pour pouvoir acheminer les voyageurs
jusqu'à jusqu'à la GAR autre chantier
qui impacte directement les usagers qui
doivent se rendre à 50 ans en yeline
sécurisation du tunnel de Medon c'est
des renforcements d'éclairage c'est des
renforcements des des à côtés c'est tout
un tas de dispositifs de de niches qui
sont mis dans dans le tunnel donc c'est
des travaux de modernisation de ce
tunnel qui sont entrepris un weekend de
travaux est prévu du 24 au 26 mai en
tout 10 chantiers majeurs sont lancés
sur la ligne C du RER 540000 voyageurs
l'empreintent
quotidiennement
comme chaque vendredi nous revenons à
présent sur l'actualité de la semaine
écoulée lundi Benoît Amon a dévoilé la
nouvelle feuille de route pour la mise
en place de la mesure phare de son
prédécesseur au ministère de l'Éducation
les rythmes scolaires l'élu yvelinois a
précisé que quelques aménagements
étaient possibles mais que l'application
devra toujours se faire dès septembre
prochain Olivier Manis calco Patrick
Jacques de
dixmud une réforme des rythmes scolaires
assouplli c'est en substance ce que
Benoît amont nouveau ministre de
l'éducation nationale a Ann annoncé
vendredi dernier principale modification
par rapport à la version précédente la
durée de la semaine pourrait être
réduite d'une heure passant de 24 à 23
heur d'enseignement hebdomadaire les 36
heures perdues annuellement seraient
donc rattrapé durant des vacances
scolaires raccourci un changement minime
qui ne sauve pas une réforme mise en
place trop rapidement et impopulaire
auprès des parents comme ici à trrappe
devant l'école jeanjourè comme
d'habitude nos amis technocrates
prennent des décisions sans jamais
concerter le peuple donc je sais pas si
c appel à
changer je sais que les trapistes ont
envie que ça change franchement je sais
pas trop mais bon si on garde ancien
rythme ça serait beaucoup mieux même si
la semaine de 4 jours et demi est
conservée l'autre nouveauté c'est la
possibilité de concentrer toutes les
activités périscolaires sur une
demi-journée mais là aussi les critiques
fusent notamment sur le contenu de ces
activités dans 80 % des communes de
France qui ont expérimenté ça se passe
comme ça ça finit en garderie donc allez
désorganiser la vie des des parents des
grands-parents des associations qui
travaillent là-dessus des animateurs des
mairies des profs des enfants surtout
tout ça pour aboutir à un tel résultat
et en plus être incapable de dire on
arrête ça ne marche pas ce qui est assez
emblématique ici on est dans la commune
sur lequel le ministre de l'éducation
est élu en tant que conseiller municipal
et on peut pas dire que ce qui est mis
en place sur trap soit exemplaire à la
fois en matière de dialogue avec les
parents et les enseignants et en matière
de de la qualité de ce qui est proposé
aux enfants 15 % des municipalités
françaises ont pour l'instant adopté
cette réforme dans leurs écoles dès la
rentrée prochaine elles seront toutes
concerné par ces nouveaux horaires une
rentrée qui s'annonce
mouvementé cette semaine a également été
la première en tant que président de
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline pour Michel logier le maire de
Montini le Bretonneux retour sur son
élection et sur le nouveau visage de
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin avec
ses extraits de son passage sur notre
plateau c'était mardi soir les priorités
déjà en premier lieu c'est d'avoir un
nouveau pacte financier vous savez que
on s'est entendu entre les les SEP
communes et la communauté d'agloot en
2010 pour partir sur des bases
financières nouvelles puisque la chambre
rionale des comptes nous avait indiqué
qu'on ne pouvait plus financer des
équipements communaux sur le budget
communautaire donc on a signé ce pacte
financier ce pacte financier qui devait
se terminer en 2013 on l'a prolongé
d'une année donc moi ma première mission
c'est de redéfinir ces nouvelles bases
afin que nous sachions chacun où nous
allons et je souhaite queon y travaille
rapidement pour qu'il soit intégré au
budget 2015 qui normalement sera voté en
fin d'année ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose c'est de effectivement
à partir d'un état des lieux de revoir
un petit peu ce qui fonctionne bien ce
qui pourrait mieux fonctionner et
peut-être donner des priorités sur les
compétences qui sont les notres
aujourd'hui aller peut-être vers de
nouveaux besoins notre société évolue il
est normal aussi que nous évoluions et
puis il y a aussi la question du
périmètre parce que là ce sont des
textes nouveaux votés par le
gouvernement actuel qui nous obligent
aujourd'hui à réfléchir sur un
territoire qui sera plus important
puisque on doit passer de 148000
habitants à plus de 200000 habitants
donc là aussi c'est une priorité puisque
il faut que cette nouvelle agglomération
soit en place au 1er janvier 2016 donc
voyez que le temps presse je veux
rassurer tous ceux qui ont travaillé ou
qui souhaitent travailler avec cette
agglomération on premier lieu déjà toute
l'équipe administrative de la communauté
d'agloot il y a aujourd'hui de nouvelles
directions donc il est important qu'il
que les collaborateurs soi rassuré je
souhaite rassurer aussi les chefs
d'entreprise qui sont là ils savent très
bien que depuis longtemps moi je
travaille avec eux j'ai souhaité que
Jean-Michel Fourgous soit le premier
vice-président en charge du
développement économique je crois que
c'est un signe très fort aussi on sait
très bien que il est euh tout à fait à
l'aise sur ce domaine-là et puis je
souhaite aussi rassurer les
investisseurs parce que on a aussi
besoin aujourd'hui d'avoir des
investisseurs qui viennent on a des
mètres carrés encore à valoriser sur
Saint-Quentin dont je souhaite aussi qui
soit rassuré sur le comportement que
nous aurons à leur égard la gauche
désormais minoritaire à 50 ans en
Yveline entend se montrer vigilante
c'est elle qui le dis sur la politique
menée en matière de culture notamment
les élus socialistes qui regrett
également n'avoir eu finalement qu'assez
peu de place au sein de l'exécutif alors
que trois des SEP communes seulement à
Saint-Quentin sont à droite on aurait pu
aller encore plus loin dans le le
partage de la gouvernance par exemple
vous avez vu que euh sur les
vice-présidents il y a des places
données avec des réelles délégations euh
à la à la gauche néanmoins en proportion
faible surtout quand on pense que trois
délégués sont ajoutés et uniquement pour
la droite donc on commence avec un bon
principe mais on l'applique pas jusqu'au
bout ça sera notre rôle de veiller à ce
qu'il soit mieux appliqué en tout cas
nous y prendrons toute notre part après
j'ai noté qu'il y avait une volonté de
continuité par rapport à la préservation
de la réussite de 50 ans en Yveline je
dois dire à titre personnel que je je
serais très très attentif à la poursuite
des services de qualité auprès des
habitants parce que nous sommes là pour
les habitants j'ajoute également que euh
j'ai trouvé des manques c'est sur euh la
question de la culture euh l'avenir par
rapport à la culture cont tenu des
déclarations antérieures dans le mandat
précédent je serai là aussi très très
attentif à voir que les dispositifs
culturels je pense notamment à l'aide
aux associations aux compagnies au
fonctionnement des équipements culturels
soit importante dès lors que et ça a été
rappelé nous sommes ville d'art et
d'histoire et nous sommes aussi ville de
culture politique toujours et les
élections européennes le 25 mai modem et
udi qui lancent leur campagne sous une
étiquette commune l'alternative en
île-de-fance Marielle de Sarnez et
Jean-Marie Cavada sont tête de liste ils
avaient donné rendez-vous à la presse à
la Maison Jean-M c'est à sur Guillon
dans les yelines donc en 2009 lors du
précédent scrutin européen le modem
avait totalisé 9 % en Île-deFrance et 10
% dans le département Catherine zulato
claire Cambier et Jonathan villman l'UDI
et le modem sous la même bannière pour
dire oui à l'Europe et affirmer leur
euro optimisme on a besoin vitalement
d'Europe pour aller créer notre propre
croissance pour aider pour l'emploi pour
avoir de nouveaux outils de nouveaux
instruments par exemple de mobiliser
lesp européenne pour des grands travaux
par exemple qu'on a besoin d'une
politique européenne en matière
d'immigration avec des frontières
extérieures de l'Europe qui soient gardé
avec un corps de garde-côte donc une une
politique européenne on a besoin de plus
d'Europe pour la défense pour la
politique étrangère la liste udi modem
présente 12 engagements pour l'Europe
autour de trois thèmes majeurs l'emploi
avec une politique industrielle à
définir la démocratie avec la volonté de
donner plus la parole aux habitants par
le biais d'initiativ citoyennes et et la
protection les centristes entendent
ainsi mettre un terme à la politique
d'élargissement des frontières un
programme construit qui cherche aussi à
convaincre les Français de l'étranger
car pour cette élection ils sont invités
à voter dans la circonscription de
l'île-de-fance 2 millions sont inscrits
il faut donc les séduire et parmi les
colistiers un ivelinois Bruno milien qui
a vécu à l'étranger le regard qu'ont les
pays étrangers à la fois sur la France à
la fois sur l'Europe je dirais que c'est
des regards teintés d'émerveillement
avec des petites étoiles dans les yeux
et j'ai envie que ce rêve là qui existe
à l'étranger vis-à-vis de l'Europe et
vis-à-vis de la France existe aussi en
France moi je suis
absolument pas catastrophé mais déçu de
voir autant de populisme monter en
France vis-à-vis de l'Europe au Trib
Linois présent sur cette liste de 30
candidats Flavien bazenet conseiller
municipal d'opposition udi a joué en
Josas soutenu par le patron
départemental c'est une liste
extrêmement engagée de gens qui sont
pétris d'Europe qui ça au fond de leur
trip voilà alors certains il y a eu des
témoignages vous avez vu on dit qu'ils
avaient ils étaient nés avec cette
Europe il faut passer une marche
supplémentaire pour avoir plus de
cohésion sociale les colistiers
souhaitent mener une campagne de terrain
une réunion publique se tiendra le 20
mai à Versailles le temps presse les
élections européennes se jouent à un
seul tour le dimanche 25 mai est-ce que
ça vous
va le Front de Gauche mène également
campagne pour ces européennes dans le
département des yvelin c'est la Numéro 2
en île-defance Raquel garido qui s'est
rendu à poissie cette semaine auprès des
salariés de P sa représentante du Parti
de Gauche au côté de l'eurodéputé
sortant le communiste Patrick leyar elle
a souhaité dénoncer les pratiques du
constructeur automobile et le programme
test baptisé runs qui vise à augmenter
la cadence de production de Peugeot à 60
véhicules par heure bah justement
transformer cette colère qui est une
colère saine dans une action civique une
action citoyenne qui est la seule façon
de de de prendre du pouvoir quand on n
pas de pouvoir économique la concurrence
libre de tous contre tous que ce soit au
niveau mondial ou au niveau européen
n'apporte rien de bon et qu'en réalité
il faudrait que dans chaque pays on
produise ce dont on a besoin chez nous
pour nous si l'Europe a quelque chose à
apporter on va dire à l'humanité comme
proposition politique c'est ça c'est le
protectionnisme solidaire pour mettre en
œuvre un modèle de société qui soit
écologique qui soit social l'actualité
de cette semaine c'est aussi la sortie
d'mé en vérité ouvrage de Pierre Hervé
Grosjean abbé de la paroisse de
saint-sir l'école il évoque relation
amoureuse et sexualité les a priori de
l'église à ce sujet il était très engagé
contre le mariage pour tous il a
d'ailleurs beaucoup communiqué sur les
réseaux sociaux il lui arrive encore
aujourd'hui de poster des dizaines de
messages par jour sur Twitter l'abé
Grogan était l'invité du journal
mercredi soir dans le cœur de tous les
jeunes que je peux rencontrer et j'en
rencontre beaucoup parce que je suis au
lycée parce qu'on prépare des couples au
mariage parce que on accompagne aussi
beaucoup de jeunes dans dans notre
paroisseou dans les homoneries euh il y
a une un point commun chez tous qu'il
soit chrétien ou non c'est ce désir
profond d'aimer et d'être aimé et ce
sentiment que seul un amour véritable
durable pourra combler voilà et du coup
ce que je trouve génial c'est d'apporter
cette expérience de l'église ça fait
2000 ans qu'elle accompagne les hommes
et les femmes dans cet apprentissage de
l'amour d'accompagner non pas de de
choisir à la place mais d'accompagner
d'être à côté pour là encore éclairer le
discernement de chacun pour donner euh
les critères de ce discernement pour
aider à se poser les bonnes questions et
pour encourager chacun euh à construire
sur du vrai et peut-être être un peu
libre par rapport à ce qui est trop
facile il ne faut pas culpabiliser il
faut accompagner ces jeunes c'est le
message que que vous souhaitez faire
passer pour autant vous écrivez ce n'est
pas à 25 ans qu'on se prépare au mariage
c'est à 15 ans ce que vous viez à 15 ans
et plus prépare déjà l'épouse et l'époux
que vous serez à 25 30 ans vous faites
peser un poids très très lourd sur les
actes et les actions de de ces
adolescents au contraire je pense qu'on
les encourage plutôt que de leur dire
fais pas ça fais pas ça fais attention
on a dit mais tu te rends compte tu es
tu es à l'époque des fondations et donc
c'est maintenant que tu peux que tu peux
être exigeant c'est maintenant que tu
peux apprendre je te demande pas d'y
arriver d'un coup h mais je je te crois
euh c'est ce que c'est ça que dit
l'église l'Église nous aime assez pour
nous croire responsable et capable du
meilleur et capable d'entendre
qu'effectivement à 15 ans à 18 ans à 20
ans ce qu'on vit nous engage je repose
quand même la question très clairement
sur le port du préservatif pour ceux qui
n'arrivent pas vous dites le message
c'est pas non plus de dire faut y
arriver tout de suite faut les
accompagner donc mettons début il n'y
arrive pas quel quel message vous leur
dites vous leur dit si vous pêchez fait
avec un préservatif ou si vous avez pas
besoin encore encore une fois le message
que propose l'Église c'est un message
qui qu' propose à la liberté de chacun
si vous n'avez pas besoin du feu vert de
l'église pour coucher ensemble vous
n'avez pas besoin non plus de faire de
l'église pour mettre une capote c'est
clair bien sûr qu'il faut être
responsable mais encore une fois le rôle
de l'Église c'est pas c'est pas de de de
de de vous de vous tendre la boîte de
préservatif le rôle de l'Église c'est de
vous apprendre à aimer voyez si vous les
gens et je crois vraiment que les les
gens se trompent parfois les gens
n'attendent pas de l'église qu'ell parle
comme la radio comme mais pour autant
les gens qui viennent vous voir aussi
ont une fois ont des croyances et ils
attendent de savoir s'ils sont ou non
dans le péché sils peuvent attendez je
leur dis je leur dis je leur dis le
mieux c'est ça maintenant tu vas y aller
en progressant peut-être pas à pas mais
le mieux c'est d'apprendre à aimer et de
te donner justement de façon fidèle
d'attendre d'être prêt pour te donner et
donc d'attendre d'être engagé pour te
donner ça c'est le mieux une idée de
loisir pour ce weekend mais aussi
l'occasion de faire une bonne action le
Lyon club de la Vallée de Chevreuse qui
organise une soirée au profit de la
association Laurette fugin une soirée
tarot et belotte pour les amateurs ce
sera le samedi 3 mai à l'espace
jean-rassine à Saint-Rémi les chevreuses
l'association laorette fugin qui lutte
vous le savez contre la leucémie depuis
maintenant 2002 et puis une autre
association mise en lumière c'était
mardi au golf de Saint-Non la bretche
mesenna chirurgie et cardiaque le
comédien danib boun était présent lors
d'un tournoi caritatif l'association
permet à des enfants souffrant de
malformation de venir en France et
d'être opéré lorsqu'ils ne peuvent pas
être soignés dans leur pays d'origine
par manque de moyens financi ci et
technique mais c chirurgie cardiaque a
déjà aidé plus de 2000 enfants depuis sa
création en
1996 le trophée de golf trophée du cœur
solidaire fait sa 17e édition et Dani
boun était donc présent on l'écoute
c'est une histoire de coup de cœur et
après de de dire et enfin après je voilà
aprèsil faut c'est être là disponible
pour pour aider la situation et mettre
mettre ma notoriété au service de de de
la récole de de fond quoi
voilà de ce journal prochaine édition en
direct lundi 18h je recevrai le
porte-parole du collectif contre
l'esclavage 6e édition de cette
mobilisation à Saint-Quentin en Eveline
d'ici là excellent
[Musique]
weekend